but let us return for a time to aliens
so you started to define sort of the
the model the parameters
of uh grabbiness
right or the uh
as we approach crabbiness so what
happens so again there's three
parameters yes
there's the speed at which they expand
there's the rate at which they appear in
time and that rate has a constant and a
power so we've talked about the history
of life on earth suggests that power is
around six but maybe three to twelve
we can say that constant comes from our
current date sort of sets the overall
rate
and the speed which is the last
parameter comes from the fact that we
look in the sky we don't see them so the
model predicts very strongly that if
they were expanding slowly say one
percent of the speed of light
our sky would be full of vast spheres
that were full of activity that is
at a random time when a civilization is
first appearing if it looks out into its
sky it would see many other grabby alien
civilizations in the sky and they would
be much bigger than the full moon they'd
be huge spheres in the sky and they
would be visibly different we don't see
them can we pause for a second
okay there's a bunch of hard steps that
earth had to pass to arrive at this
place we are currently which we're
starting to launch rockets out into
space we're kind of starting to expand a
bit right very slowly okay
but this is like the birth
if you look at the entirety of the
history of earth
we're now at this precipice of like
expansion we could we might not choose
to but if we do we will do it in the
next 10 million years
10 million wow
time flies when you're having fun
uh i was thinking a short time on the on
the cosmological scale so that is it
might be only a thousand but the point
is if it's even if it's up to 10 million
that hardly makes any difference to the
model so i might as well give you 10
million this this makes me feel i was i
was so stressed about planning what i'm
gonna do today and now right you've got
plenty of time plenty of time
uh i just need to be generating some
offspring quickly here okay um
so and there's this moment
[Laughter]
this 10 million uh year gap uh or window
when we start expanding and you're
saying okay so this is an interesting
moment where there's a bunch of other
alien civilizations that might at some
history of the universe arrived at this
moment were here they passed all the
hard steps there's a there's a model for
how
likely it is that that happens and then
they start expanding and you think of an
expansion as almost like a sphere
right that's when you say speed we're
talking about the speed of the radius
growth exactly like the surface how fast
the surface
okay and so you're saying that there's
some speed for that expansion average
speed and then we can play with that
parameter
and
if that speed is super slow then maybe
that explains
why we haven't seen anything if it's
super fast well guess the slow would
create the puzzle it's low predicts we
would see them but we don't see them
okay so the way to explain that is that
they're fast so the idea is
if they're moving really fast then we
don't see them until they're almost here
and okay this is counterintuitive all
right hold on a second so i think this
works best when i say a bunch of dumb
things okay um
and then uh
you uh elucidate
the full complexity and the beauty of
the dumbness okay
so there's the spheres out there in the
universe that are made visible because
they're sort of uh using a lot of energy
so they're generating a lot of light
they're changing things they're changing
things and change
would be visible
a long way off yes that would take apart
stars rearrange them restructure
galaxies they would just be kind of big
huge stuff
okay if they're expanding slowly
we would see a lot of them
because the universe is old as relative
is old enough to where we would see that
we're assuming we're just typical you
know maybe at the 50th percentile of
them so like half of them have appeared
so far the other half will still appear
later
and um
the math of our best estimate is that
they appear roughly once per million
galaxies
and we would meet them in roughly a
billion years
if uh we expanded out to meet them so
we're looking at a grabby aliens model
3d sim right
what's what's this that's the actual
name of the video what uh by the time we
get to 13.8 billion years
the fun begins
okay so this is this is a um right we're
watching a
three-dimensional sphere rotating i
presume that's the universe and then
right the aliens are expanding and
filling that universe exactly with all
kinds of uh and then pretty soon it's
all full it's full so that's how
the grabby aliens come
in contact first of all with other
aliens
and then um with us humans the following
is a simulation of the grabby aliens
model of alien civilizations
civilizations are born that expand
outwards at constant speed a spherical
region of space is shown by the time we
get to 13.8 billion years
this sphere will be about 3 000 times as
wide as the distance from the milky way
to andromeda
okay this is fun it's huge okay it's
huge um all right
so
why don't we see
uh we're one little tiny tiny tiny tiny
dot in that giant giant sphere right why
don't we
see any of the grabby aliens
it depends on how fast they expand
so you could see that if they expanded
at the speed of light you wouldn't see
them until they were here
so like out there if somebody is
destroying the universe with a
vacuum decay there's this there's this
you know doomsday scenario where
somebody somewhere could change the
vacuum of the universe and that would
expand at the speed of light and
basically destroy everything it hit but
you'd never see that until i got here
because it's expanding at the speed of
light
if you're spinning really slow then you
see it from a long way off so the fact
we don't see anything in the sky tells
us they're expanding fast say over a
third the speed of light and that's
really really fast
but that's what you have to believe if
you look out and you don't see anything
now you might say well how maybe i just
don't want to believe this whole model
why should i believe this whole model at
all and
our best evidence why you should believe
this model is our early date
we are right now
almost 14 million years into the
universe
on a
planet around a star that's roughly 5
billion years old
but the average star out there will last
roughly five trillion years
that is
a thousand times longer
and remember that power law it says that
the chance of advanced life appearing on
a planet goes as the power of sixth of
the time so if a planet lasts a thousand
times longer
then the chance of it appearing on that
planet if everything would stay empty at
least is a thousand to the sixth power
or ten to the eighteen
so
enormous
overwhelming chance that if the universe
would just stay sit and empty and
waiting for advanced life to appear when
it would appear would be
way at the end of all these
planet lifetimes that is the long
planets
near the end of the lifetime trillions
of years into the future so but we're
really early compared to that and our
explanation is at the moment as you saw
in the video the universe is filling up
in roughly a billion years it'll all be
full and at that point it's too late for
advanced life to show up so you had to
show up now before that deadline okay
can we break that apart a little bit
okay
or linger on some of the things you said
so with the power law the things we've
done on earth
the model you have says that it's very
unlikely like we're lucky sobs
is that is that mathematically correct
to say
we we're crazy early that is when early
means like in the history of the
universe in the history okay so
given this model
how do we make sense of that if we're
super can we just be the lucky ones
well 10 to the 18 lucky you know how
lucky do you feel
uh so you know
that's pretty lucky right you know 10 to
18 is a billion billion
so then if you were just being honest
and humble
that that means
what does that mean it means one of the
assumptions that calculated this crazy
early must be wrong yeah that's what it
means so the key assumption we suggest
is that the universe would stay empty
so
most life would appear like a thousand
times longer later than now yeah if
everything would stay empty waiting for
it to appear what was so what is
non-empty so the gravity aliens are
filling the universe right now roughly
at the moment they've filled half of the
universe and they've changed it and when
they fill everything it's too late for
stuff like us to appear but wait hold on
a
second did anyone help us get lucky
if it's so difficult what how do
like so it's like cancer right
there's all these cells each of which
randomly does or doesn't get cancer
and eventually some cell gets cancer and
you know we were one of those
but hold on a second
okay
but we got it early
early compared to the prediction with an
assumption that's wrong that's so that's
how we do a lot of you know theoretical
analysis you have a model that makes a
prediction that's wrong then that helps
you reject that model okay let's try to
understand exactly where the wrong is so
the assumption is that the universe
is empty stays empty stays empty and and
waits until this advanced life appears
in trillions of years
that is if the universe would just stay
empty if there was just
you know nobody else out there yeah then
when you should expect advanced life to
appear if you're the only one in the
universe when should you expect to
appear you should expect to appear
trillions of years in the future
i see right right so this is a very sort
of nuanced mathematical
uh assumption i don't think we can
intuit it
cleanly with words
but if you assume
that you're just wait the universe stays
empty and you're waiting for
one
life
uh civilization to pop up
then it's gonna it should happen very
late much later than now and
if you look at earth
uh the way things happen on earth it
happened much much much much much
earlier than it was supposed to
according to this model if you take the
initial assumption therefore you can say
well the initial assumption of the
universe staying empty is very unlikely
right
and the other the other alternative
theory is the universe is filling up and
will fill up soon
and so
we are typical for the origin date of
things that can appear before the
deadline before that okay it's filling
up so why don't we see anything if it's
filling up because they're expanding
really fast
close to the speed of light exactly so
we will only see it when it's here
almost here
okay
uh what are the ways in which we might
see a quickly expanding
this is both exciting and terrifying it
is terrifying it's like watching a truck
like driving at you at 100 miles an hour
and uh so we would see spheres in the
sky at least one sphere in the sky
growing very rapidly
and
like very rapidly right
yes very rapidly
so we're not
so there's there's you know different
def because we were just talking about
10 million years this would be
you might see it 10 million years in
advance coming i mean you still might
have a long warning or again
the universe is 14 billion years old
the typical origin times of these things
are spread over several billion years so
the chance of one originating at a you
know very close to you in time is very
low so
it still might take millions of years
from the time you see it from the time
it gets here
you've got a million years of your years
to be terrified there's a lot of spirit
coming at you but but coming at you very
fast so if they're traveling close to
the speed of light but they're coming
from a long way away so remember
the rate at which they appear is one per
million galaxies
right
so they're roughly 100 galaxies away
i see so the delta between the speed of
light
and their actual travel speed is very
important
right so even if they're going at say
half the speed of light we'll have a
long time
yeah but what if they're traveling
exactly at a speed of light then we'd
see them like then we wouldn't have much
warning but that's less likely well we
can't exclude it
and they could also be somehow traveling
faster than the speed of light
or not i think we can exclude because if
they could go faster than speed of light
then they would just already be
everywhere
so in a universe where you can travel
faster than the speed of light you can
go backwards in space time so any time
you appeared anywhere in space time you
could just fill up everything yeah and
so anybody in the future whoever
appeared they would have been here by
now can you exclude the possibility that
those kinds of aliens aren't already
here
uh
well you have we should have a different
discussion of that right okay so let's
actually lead that let's leave that
discussion aside just to linger and
understand the grabby alien expansion
which is beautiful and fascinating
okay
so there's these giant expanding spheres
spheres of alien civilizations now
uh
when those fears spheres collide
mathematically
it was it's very likely that we're not
the first
collision of grabby
of alien civilizations i suppose there's
one way to say it so there's like the
first time the spheres touch each other
would recognize each other right they
meet
um they they recognize each other first
before they meet
um they see each other coming they see
each other coming and then so there's a
bunch of them there's a combinatorial
thing where they start seeing each other
coming and then there's a third neighbor
it's like what the hell and then there's
a fourth one okay so what does that you
think look like um what lessons
from human nature that's the only data
we have
well can you draw the story of the
history of the universe here yes is what
i would call a living cosmology so
what i'm excited about in part by this
model is that it lets us tell a story of
cosmology where there are actors who
have agendas
so most ancient peoples they had
cosmologies the stories they told about
where the universe came from and where
it's going and what's happening out
there and their stories they like to
have agents and actors gods or something
out there doing things and lately our
favorite cosmology is dead kind of
boring
you know we're the only activity we know
about or see and everything else just
looks dead and empty but
this is now telling us no that's not
quite right at the moment the universe
is filling up and in a few billion years
it'll be all full
and from then on the history of the
universe will be the universe full of
aliens
yeah so that's a it's a really good
reminder a really good way to think
about cosmology is
we're surrounded by vast darkness and we
don't know what's going on in that
darkness
until the light
from whatever generate lights arrives
here
so we kind of yeah we look up at the sky
okay they're stars oh they're pretty but
you don't think about
the giant expanding spheres of aliens
right
see them but
now you're approaching
looking at the clock if you're clever
the clock tells you so i like the
analogy with the ancient greeks so yes
you might think that an ancient greek
you know staring at the universe
couldn't possibly tell how far away the
sun was or how far away the moon is or
how big the earth is
that all you can see is just big things
in the sky you can't tell but they were
clever enough actually to be able to
figure out the size of the earth and the
distance to the moon and the sun and the
size of the moon
and sun that is they could figure those
things out actually by being clever
enough and so similarly we can actually
figure out where are the aliens out
there in space time by being clever
about the few things we can see one of
which is our current date and
so now that you have this living
cosmology we can tell the story that the
universe starts out empty and then at
some point things like us appear very
primitive and then some of those
stop being quiet and expand and then for
a few billion years they expand and then
they meet each other and then for the
next 100 billion years they commune with
each other
that is the usual models of cosmology
say that in roughly
150 billion years
the expansion of the universe will
happen so much that all you'll have left
is some galaxy clusters and they that
are sort of disconnected from each other
but before then for the next 100 million
years 100 billion years excuse me
they will interact there will be this
community of all the grabby alien
civilizations and each one of them will
hear about and even meet thousands of
others
and we might hope to join them someday
and become part of that community that's
an interesting thing to aspire to
you